Thanks forming your experience on the
defensive side of the ball let's start
with your perspective when you're
playing defense it makes sense to have
the camera behind you so we've
introduced some new defensive cameras
that will allow you to read and attack
the offense right in front of you next
if you're a defender and you get locked
into a block that's no fun now you'll
have much more control you choose the
direction to push your opponent during a
battle you can push them to the side to
close up a running Lane or you can push
them forward to disrupt the pocket you
can shut a block or use a pass-rush move
to break free and take down the QB and
open field tackling has always been a
challenge so we've redesigned how you
make a tackle to get more consistent
results a tiered tackle cone makes it
easier to zero in on the ball carrier
and set up the appropriate attack
conservative tackles are the most
reliable giving you the greatest chance
to take down your opponent or you can
take a risk with an aggressive tackle
but it'll take more skill up close you
can pull off a big hit further away you
can dive towards the ball carrier to
stop him in his tracks look I could go
on and on about all the defensive
improvements in mine 15 but here's the
point you're going to have more control
on defense than ever before now instead
of feeling like a liability on defense
you're going to have a lot more fun we
also want you to feel the intensity of
the NFL so we've added hundreds of new
player emotions and reactions these play
out in real time on the field replacing
old scripted scenes and we've paired
them with a new set of dramatic
presentation cameras all directed by an
Emmy award-winning cinematographer from
NFL Films if you watch NFL films like I
do you know they're the best in the
world that's showcasing the emotion of
football and now you'll experience that
in madden 15 for those of you at e3 this
week we invite you to come play it and
to everyone else you can experience it
firsthand when man 15 launches on august
26th